starting with some questions from
facebook
grim re
asks uh
in terms of hypertrophy is there any
significant difference between only
doing one exercise targeting the
particular muscle you're trying to train
and five different exercises as long as
volume and intensity are matched
uh so overall it shouldn't make that big
of a difference as far as just kind of
like overall muscle hypertrophy goes
there have been two or three studies
looking at this just training a muscle
with only one exercise versus a
combination of different exercises
and you don't tend to see
particularly notable differences in
terms of just overall kind of global
gross measures of
increases in muscle size but what you do
see pretty frequently
is differences in terms of regional
hypertrophy so for example
if you only trained your quads with one
quad exercise versus a variety of quad
exercises um
you know your your total increase in
quadriceps cross-sectional area will
probably be pretty comparable regardless
but using a variety of exercises helps
ensure that all four heads of the
quadriceps are
more evenly developed
whereas like you know maybe you might
have more say preferential vastus
lateralis development uh or
vastus medialis development or something
like that if you only used one exercise
uh similarly um there's a study we've
talked about on the podcast before
looking at triceps growth following uh
just doing skull crushers versus bench
press versus a combination of skull
crushers and bench press and the skull
skull crushers and bench press were both
independently pretty good for overall
triceps growth
but the
skull crushers seem to be particularly
good for the long head of the triceps
which is biarticular
and the bench press seem to be
particularly good for the monoarticular
heads of the triceps like the the two
that don't cross the shoulder joint
and a combination of both uh skull
crushers and bench press seemed to be
uh necessary or at least beneficial to
ensure that all of the heads of the
triceps grew pretty robustly
um so yeah i i don't think you strictly
need
a bunch of exercise variety just for
just to get big in general
but if regional hypertrophy
matters to you or if ensuring even
development of all of the heads of a
particular muscle matters quite a bit to
you
then there might be benefits for more
exercise variety